okay so now you see the world like this
you see the world
you said you started to see the world
primarily through the center
periphery dichotomy and that's one
that's that's an
easy way to understand it okay at some
point they transcend those
those categories but that's the the best
way to explain it i think is
is is using hierarchy uh like a like a
mountain or pyramid or
centroid periphery those are the best
way to explain it so now when you watch
something like a movie
how do you see the movie yeah what are
you looking for
are you looking for anything does it
just unconsciously hit you and you
realize it just hits me
it doesn't i don't uh i usually just
watch a movie
and then i'll take a little bit of time
and uh and then i i have insights can
you give me an example of your thought
process
from a a very recent movie so that it's
fresh in your mind
so some movie that you saw recently that
you went in thinking
okay i'm just gonna watch this movie and
then what thoughts occurred to you
and then what thoughts occurred to you
afterwards okay uh
so okay what did i i just went to see
shazam with my kids i went to see that
movie
uh and uh
so the movie shazam is about a young man
a young boy who becomes a superhero
an adult superhero right and uh
and he and the movie is for example
one of the images that keeps appearing
in the movie is an image of the carnival
and the carnival keeps coming back and
so for example like if if an image like
that keeps coming back
especially the carnival then you say
okay i need to pay attention
to this because there's something going
on here
and uh and so so a carnival for example
is
is this edge the carnival is the edge of
the world
the best way to understand it it's
everything's upside down right
everything's spinning
everything in a carnival is spinning all
the time you know the ferris wheel all
the rides everything's spinning
and and uh and everything is is uh
is is uh garish you know all the colors
are garish
everything is there to to to uh
titillate you
in that's in that way so it's all bad
food it's all
it's all spinning it's all uh laughing
and pleasure
in in the very basis sense of of having
fun
you know and clowns and uh uh
and impossible um impossible uh
precision games where you try to hit the
center but you're not going to hit the
center
no one is the center right no one get
all those precision games where you win
these big things like
it's they're they're very difficult so
it's like okay so this is what's going
on
and so then you think okay so the story
is about in this
i don't want to give all these spoilers
but the story in the in
shazam is about dealing with the seven
deadly sins
and so it's like okay so here's all of
this going on at the same time so
these seven deadly sins kind of come out
and possess
this one man you know and then
they they start to kind of attack the
world and do all this stuff
so okay so the seven deadly sins at a
carnival
it all kind of makes sense it's like it
all kind of fits together
it's not trying to say anything right
it's not it's not like there's a message
but the pattern is right and so when the
pattern is right
where the seven deadly sins appear at a
carnival
it's like it fits and then you when you
look at when you're watching it
you you have a kind of satisfaction
which is the satisfaction of the world
being right even if
it's talking about the upside down world
right it's talking about these monstrous
seven deadly passions that are coming to
to suck to suck up the world but it's
having it in a carnival
which is an upside-down world already
and so all of this is going on and so
it's like even though it's showing you
the
the extremes it's fits because it's
everything's in the right place
and so when when sometimes what can
happen is if
you could have it you could have a place
where it just is wrong where it just
doesn't
doesn't work where it's and that and
that's because
you're interpreting it incorrectly or
you feel like it's being forced on the
part of the filmmaking worst
exactly it's just being forced so
there's a desire to
to give a message and so they'll push
something
in which will which will force it but
the best way to force it is to
because it's difficult to get away from
these patterns because they're the
patterns of reality
all you can do is you can you can make
them upside down
you can uh twist them right so you can't
totally get rid of them
and so i think that a lot of the the
modern kind of propaganda
that's what they do is they they twist
them in a way they kind of just
toss them to it make them in like the
idea of yes we need
we can't avoid the masculine feminine
archetypes
so what we'll do is we'll put a woman in
the place of the masculine figure and
put a man in the place of the feminine
figure and demean the man
sorry and i mean the man denigrate him
so it's like so we're still using the
same pattern
but we're just doing in a way that's
kind of flipping it upside down or
playing with it in a way that is is
confusing or is
meant to create uh disjunction you could
say